how does a family sitcom manage to
portray innocent subjects like camping
trips parental advice and even the film
It's a Wonderful Life in a way that
wouldn't fly today Married with Children
has plenty of examples
it seems as though men in the 80s
thought the only place that sold bras
were sex shops because in season 3
episode 6 her cups runeth over the scene
is written like a teenager's sexual
fantasy Al freaks out when tasked with
buying a bra for his wife eager for the
experience his friend Steve joins and of
course every woman in the place is a
scantily clad Playboy Bunny type seeing
that the show is a raunchy comedy aimed
towards men the overall fantasy element
could make sense in that context the
blatant objectification of women however
is surprising when Al is asked for his
wife's cup size he holds his hands
millimeters from a woman's breasts for
comparison and she doesn't seem to think
it's inappropriate the camera then looks
the sales woman up and down as Al says
let's see the Japanese build a better
one of those
moments later Al catches Steve poking at
a mannequin's breasts and Steve responds
with a line that certainly wouldn't fly
today oh come on Al uh she was asking
for you see how she's dressed it's not
just that Al Bundy doesn't find
overweight women attractive he openly
shames and ridicules them Bundy's fat
shaming one-liners became a staple of
the show but we're surprised the
tasteless gag kept running deep into its
final season in season 11 episode 9
crimes against obesity years of
insensitive jokes that Bundy hurled at
the shoe store's female customers come
to a head as an army of his past targets
marched through his door tie him to a
chair and put him on trial for you
guessed it crimes against obesity Al's
singers are obviously problematic but
the fact that the show doesn't really
take the opportunity to have the
character see the error of his ways
really doubles down on the hurtful
message that would not fly in a 2020
landscape after the judge yells for
order the women instinctively yell fast
food orders like Big Mac and
Filet-O-Fish later Peg testifies that
her obese mother ate her on Edna because
she was standing too close to some pies
but by season 7 Married with Children
was delving deeper into the 90s a decade
that was starting to become known for
its more Progressive views at least
compared to the notoriously conservative
1980s in season 7 episode 23 Pegg who
doesn't even have a job gets fired up
over undocumented people taking all the
jobs she tells Al why every day more
illegal immigrants some of whom speak
English
are out there flooding the job market
then she continues by delivering an
unflattering stereotypical impersonation
later in the episode Al's new boss
introduces him to his Indian co-workers
after that Al tells them I was selling
shoes when you guys were just a gleam in
a New York taxi cab driver's eyes
the AV club reported of Al Bundy he was
more openly bigoted than Archie Bunker
and more skeptical of the people around
him than George Jefferson
what should have been season three's
tenth episode I'll see you in court
freaked out the fox Network's standards
and practices department so badly that
it ended up being pulled from the air
altogether commonly referred to as the
Lost episode it wound up airing on FX in
2002 the timing of which makes a little
more sense given the popularity of
non-consensual sex tape related humor
during that era one of the questionable
scenes begins with Peg and Al visiting a
City Motel to spice up their love life
the couple stumbles upon a sex tape of
their neighbors Marcy and Steve and
after having sex themselves they
realized that the motel has hidden
cameras set up to secretly film people
engaging in Intercourse when the bundies
sue the motel the court rules against
them after judging that their sex tape
was only a few seconds long and could
not technically be considered sex
since this scene takes place during
season 9 episode 10 by this point fans
had almost a decade of experience with
the show's flip-flopping between
surprisingly sensitive and rigid views
on anything that strayed from
heteronormative Behavior the
aforementioned bra shopping scene
includes a huge laugh at the idea of men
being married to each other and while a
gay man tries on a tiara Al remarks and
they wonder why we call him queen as
archaic as these jokes seem today some
may find them pretty tame compared to
the show's treatment of a post-op trans
woman the main plot of the episode dud
bowl is a reunion of Al's high school
football team when Al's old quarterback
Thad arrives at the door in a dress the
football team looks horrified in the
crowd erupts in laughter Peg is happy to
see Thad but Al blurts out sad you look
foreign
thinking that Thad is pulling a prank Al
needs proof that Thad has transitioned
and in an utterly shocking move by any
standard actually reaches down and pulls
up thad's dress in front of the entire
football team what would now be widely
considered humiliating demeaning and
illegal is laughed off by thaad and
buttoned with Al's joke we don't get
tired of our cars too we don't rip the
doors off
not only is this scene deeply offensive
but it ends with a clumsy confusing
metaphor the stigma surrounding
breastfeeding in public was alive and
well at Gary's shoes and the scene in
question ironically opens as Al and
Griff are about to expose themselves for
a measuring contest in an open well-lit
store but then a customer walks in to
interrupt because clearly full frontal
male nudity wasn't going to take place
on network television then a woman with
a baby walks in and when she starts
breastfeeding Al tells her to shut it
off Griff follows by telling her who's
on down the road
the season 9 episode business sucks
aired in 1994 and as USA Today reported
it would take almost 25 years for public
breastfeeding to be declared legal in
all 50 states
when season 5 episode 2 aired in 1990
the then unknown Pamela Anderson had
only shown up in a few bit Parts on
television she was still about a year
away from booking a recurring role on
Home Improvement and two years from her
breakout role on Baywatch in the episode
Alan Kelly Bundy pretend to be sick to
avoid visiting Peggy's mom Al could not
be more thrilled to enjoy some time
alone but Kelly spoils his staycation by
actually getting sick and becoming very
needy the numerous moments that the show
couldn't get away with today kick off
when Al watches an episode of a show
called psycho dad from there he
fantasizes about and even mimes shooting
peg in the head for not cooking in a
dream he and a beautiful woman played by
Anderson begin fooling around while he
gropes his pillow in reality seeking
comfort of very ill Kelly interrupts the
Fantasy by jumping on her father while
his daughter is lying on his chest Al
asks himself what the psycho dad would
do and then continues making out with
his pillow
we're not surprised that Al Bundy and
his strip club frequenting buddies
started a men's rights activist group
but we do wonder how all that
Unapologetic sexism got on television no
ma'am the National Organization of men
against Amazonian masterhood was founded
by Bundy in season 8 after women's
bowling night replaced men's bowling
night and their local strip club started
hosting women's poetry night at one
point no ma'am takes over a beloved
female-driven talk show to give their
demands you guys want a ladies night
try having it in the kitchen cooking for
a man
the men continue by making several more
demands including some related to
activities in the bedroom in retaliation
Amanda burst's character Marcy Darcy
starts Fang feminists against
Neanderthal guys this becomes one of the
show's best ongoing feuds partially
because much like their characters Burse
and O'Neill had issues getting along
off-screen things got tense after
O'Neill wasn't invited to burst his
wedding he asked her to explain and she
told him she didn't think he'd take it
seriously in a chat with the archive of
American television he recalled asking
births what is funny about two women in
tuxedos walking down the church aisle
O'Neal went on to share that burst was
probably not wrong for excluding him
because ultimately he had thought it was
funny
during the fourth season of Married With
Children which aired between 1989 and
1990 Sam Kinison was one of the biggest
comedians in America producers thought
his out loud abrasive style was perfect
for the show so he was given a guest
appearance in The Season's two-part
Christmas special its abundiful life in
the two-part episode he played Al's
Guardian Angel sent to show him a world
where he doesn't exist
spicy parody of It's a Wonderful Life
has Alan kinnison walking around Al's
much classier and happier family in an
alternate reality after stating that
he's depressed Kennison takes advantage
of an unsuspecting Peg by grabbing her
butt Al doesn't protest the action in
any way or remind kinnison about consent
laws after committing this sexual
assault Kinison delves into a rant about
his ex-wife before disappearing the show
and the hysterically cheering audience
may have thought this was acceptable at
the time but what kind of message did
this send to young men not that they
would stumble upon a woman existing in
an alternate reality but this highest
form of objectification sends the
unacceptable signal that an unsuspecting
woman's body is free game
in season 3 episode 4 the camping show
The Bundys go camping with Steve and
Marcy and things take an unexpected turn
when Peg Marcy and Kelly's menstrual
cycles line up as reported by Indie wire
the episode originally titled a period
piece went unaired for a month while
producers and network Executives
discussed the finer points of handling
the sensitive topic it might not seem
like a taboo subject by today's
standards but in the late 80s this was
Uncharted Territory co-creator Michael
Moye admitted to the archive of American
television I did not know and neither
did Al that when young women are
together for extended periods of time
after a while their cycle sync up I had
no idea of this Moyer went on to explain
that the episode was permitted to air
because two female staff members
confirmed that this was common knowledge
among female viewers the show could have
been praised for tackling the subject
but since male creators and writers took
the Baton we see nagging man-hating
grouches whose condition attracts wild
animals
we've focused pretty heavily on Al
Bundy's faults but make no mistake Peg
can be quite deplorable herself to give
the show some originality credit most
sitcoms of the era portrayed the husband
as a complete slob and the wife as a
straight-laced moral compass who keeps
their series grounded in reality to feed
into the show's overall misogynistic
stereotypes Peg is portrayed as a lazy
housewife who'd rather watch TV and Shop
than keep house and care for the
children no episode encapsulates this
better than season 4's rain girl in the
episode Peg has a shameful woman to
woman talk with her daughter Kelly
telling her when your husband comes home
wreaking a fear wanting some loving
you'll follow that fat rump upstairs
because you'll know that no matter how
disgusting the next three minutes will
be it still beats the hell out of work
airing in the late 80s this episode
carries the inappropriate message that
if a woman traps herself in a Loveless
marriage she never has to work an
unpleasant job ever again
[Music]